>>> THE REPUBLICAN ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF TEXAS FACES THE
POSSIBILITY OF IMPEACHMENT.
A TEXAS HOUSE VOTED UNANIMOUSLY
YESTERDAY TO RECOMMEND ARTICLES
OF IMPEACHMENT AGAINST HIM
INCLUDING ACCUSATIONS OF
BRIBERY, OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE,
AND DERELICTION OF DUTY.
HE CALLS THE INVESTIGATION
ILLEGAL.
THE FULL HOUSE CHAMBER IS
SCHEDULED TO VOTE TOMORROW
AFTERNOON.
IF IT IMPEACHES PAXTON IT MOVES
ON TO THE SENATE FOR TRIAL.
CNN'S ED LAVANDERA WITH MORE.
>> Reporter: ONE OF THE MOST
CONTROVERSIAL POLITICIANS IN
TEXAS IS FACING IMPEACHMENT.
>> THIS SHAMEFUL PROCESS WAS
CURATED FROM THE START AS AN ACT
OF POLITICAL RETRIBUTION.
>> Reporter: REPUBLICAN KEN
PAXTON HAS BEEN THE STATE'S
ATTORNEY GENERAL SINCE 2014 BUT
A TEXAS HOUSE COMMITTEE LED BY
FELLOW REPUBLICANS IS ACCUSING
PAXTON OF A LITANY OF CRIMINAL
ACTS INCLUDING BRIBERY,
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE,
DERELICTION OF DUTY, 20 ARTICLES
OF IMPEACHMENT IN ALL FILED
AGAINST HIM.
THE CHARGES BROUGHT BY THE TEXAS
HOUSE GENERAL INVESTIGATING
COMMITTEE DETAIL ALLEGED
VIOLATIONS BY THE AG AND A
REQUEST FOR MORE THAN $3 MILLION
OF PUBLIC MONEY TO PAY A LEGAL
SETTLEMENT TO WHISTLE-BLOWERS
WHO WORKED AS TOP DEPUTIES IN
THE AG'S OFFICE.
THEY REVOLTED AGAINST PAXTON IN
2020.
THERE ARE ALSO BRIBERY CHARGES
WITH A TOP CAMPAIGN DONOR THAT
INVOLVED AN ALLEGED AFFAIR.
IN A STATEMENT PAXTON SAYS THE
ALLEGATIONS ARE POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED AND BASED ON, QUOTE,
HEARSAY AND GOSSIP.
AND ALSO ADDED THAT CORRUPTED
POLITICIANS IN THE TEXAS HOUSE
ARE ACTIVELY DESTROYING TEXAS'S
POSITION AS THE MOST POWERFUL
BACK STOP AGAINST THE BIDEN
AGENDA IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
>> EVERY POLITICIAN WHO SUPPORTS
THIS DECEITFUL IMPEACHMENT
ATTEMPT WILL INFLICT LASTING
DAMAGE ON THE CREDIBILITY OF THE
TEXAS HOUSE.
>> Reporter: PAXTON HAS BEEN
UNDER INDICTMENT FOR FELONY
SECURITIES VIOLATIONS SINCE
TAKING OFFICE.
HE'S ALSO UNDER FBI
INVESTIGATION FOR HIS ACTIONS
CONNECTED TO THE ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT.
PAXTON HAS DENIED ALL WRONGDOING
AND TEXAS VOTERS HAVE RE-ELECTED
HIM AS ATTORNEY GENERAL TWICE.
ALONG THE WAY HE'S GARNERED THE
SUPPORT OF A MAJOR ALLY.
>> HE LOVES HIS STATE AND HE
LOVES THIS COUNTRY.
ATTORNEY GENERAL KEN PAXTON.
>> Reporter: AND TAKING A PAGE
OUT OF THE TRUMP PLAYBOOK PAXTON
BLAMES THE LOOMING IMPEACHMENT
FIGHT ON LIBERAL FACTIONS IN THE
TEXAS REPUBLICAN PARTY.
ONE TEXAS STATE REPRESENTATIVE
PREDICTS PAXTON WILL BE
IMPEACHED BY THE TEXAS HOUSE BUT
IS CALLING ON THE TEXAS SENATE
TO REFUSE TO HOLD AN IMPEACHMENT
TRIAL.
>> NO ONE HAS ANY EVIDENCE THAT
HE DID ANYTHING WRONG.
IT IS ALL ALLEGATIONS.
SO YES.
THIS IS JUST POLITICAL
RETRIBUTION IS ALL IT IS.
THIS IS A COMPLETE SHAM.
>> Reporter: IF THE IMPEACHMENT
PASSES IN THE TEXAS HOUSE WITH
THE MAJORITY VOTE IT MOVES ON TO
THE SENATE WHERE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S WIFE STATE SENATOR
ANGELA PAXTON COULD BE AMONG
THOSE VOTING ON HIS POTENTIAL
IMPEACHMENT.
KEN PAXTON IS URGING FRIENDS AND
SUPPORTERS TO COME PEACEFULLY TO
RALLY ON HIS BEHALF AT THE TEXAS
CAPITOL ON SATURDAY WHEN TEXAS
LAWMAKERS WILL VOTE ON THE
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT.
THIS IS SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE IT
ECHOES WHAT DONALD TRUMP DID
WITH HIS SUPPORTERS ON JANUARY
6th.
WE MUST POINT OUT KEN PAXTON WAS
ON THAT SAME STAGE WITH DONALD
TRUMP ON THAT DAY.
JOHN?
>> HE WAS INDEED.
ED LAVANDERA, THANKS SO MUCH.
I WAS LISTENING TO SOME OF THE
TESTIMONY IN THE IMPEACHMENT
COMMITTEE.
SOME OF THESE ALLEGATIONS GO
BACK TO THE VERY BEGINNING OF
HIS TENURE BACK TO 2014 AND
2015.
THERE'S BEEN A STENCH, CLOUDS OF
SMOKE AROUND KEN PAXTON FOR A
LONG TIME.
WHY NOW?
>> WELL, HE ESSENTIALLY ASKED
THE LEGISLATURE TO PARTICIPATE
IN A COVER-UP.
AS ED WAS SAYING, THERE WAS A
REQUEST FOR THIS FINE LEVIED
AGAINST HIM, MORE THAN
$3 MILLION TO SETTLE THE CLAIMS
OF THE WHISTLE-BLOWERS.
REPUBLICAN STAFFERS WHO WORKED
IN HIS OFFICE.
SO HE ASKED THE LEGISLATURE TO
PAY THAT MONEY FOR HIM.
THEY STARTED INVESTIGATING HIM
ON THAT BASIS.
AS YOU MENTIONED, THIS IS
SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN UNDER
INDICTMENT FOR NEARLY EIGHT
YEARS.
WHERE IS THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM?
WHERE IS THE FBI?
IS IT ANY WONDER THAT PEOPLE
HAVE QUALMS ABOUT THE RULE OF
LAW IN THIS COUNTRY?
HERE IS SOMEONE WHO BASICALLY,
YOU KNOW, EPITOMIZES TRUMP'S
ATTITUDE THAT IF YOU MAKE THE
LAW THEY CAN'T TOUCH YOU AND YOU
GET TO MAKE THE RULES.
BUT THERE IS A HIGHER AUTHORITY
THAN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
TEXAS AND IT LOOKS LIKE IT MAY
FINALLY BE TIME TO PAY THE
PIPER.
>> AT LEAST WE GET THE VOTE IN
THE HOUSE IT LOOKS LIKE.
WHAT IS THE SIGNIFICANCE OUTSIDE
THE BORDERS OF TEXAS?
PAXTON HAS BEEN ONE OF THE
REPUBLICAN ATTORNEYS GENERAL WHO
HAVE GONE TO COURT REPEATEDLY TO
CHALLENGE JUST ABOUT EVERYTHING
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION DOES
AND OFTEN TEXAS TAKES THE LEAD
SO THEY CAN TRY TO FIND, THEY
THINK THEY CAN FIND MORE
FAVORABLE FEDERAL JUDGES IN THE
STATE OF TEXAS.
WOULD HE JUST BE REPLACED BY
ANOTHER REPUBLICAN?
IS IT JUST ABOUT HIM OR DOES IT
HAVE BIGGER MEANING?
>> WELL, LET'S BREAK IT OUT FROM
OUTSIDE OF TEXAS AND INSIDE.
OUTSIDE OF TEXAS THE
SIGNIFICANCE IS EXACTLY WHAT YOU
SAY.
REPUBLICAN STATE ATTORNEYS
GENERAL HAVE REPEATEDLY SUED THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TO BLOCK
POLICIES BIDEN WANTS TO PURSUE
PARTICULARLY ON IMMIGRATION AND
THE ENVIRONMENT BUT ALSO THE
MIFEPRISTONE CASE AND VERY OFTEN
TEXAS IS THE LEAD PLAINTIFF
BECAUSE THAT WAY THEY CAN FIND
TRUMP APPOINTED DISTRICT OR
OTHER CONSERVATIVE DISTRICT
JUDGES IN TEXAS AND THEN HAVE A
PIPELINE FOR THE CASE TO GO
THROUGH THE FIFTH CIRCUIT COURT
OF APPEALS WHICH IS PERHAPS THE
MOST CONSERVATIVE IN THE
COUNTRY.
THIS IS SOMETHING REPUBLICANS
HAVE USED OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
SO PAXTON HAS MADE HIMSELF INTO
A HERO FOR THE MAGA BASE IN MANY
WAYS BY POSITIONING HIMSELF AS
KIND OF THE TIP OF THE SPEAR IN
THE LEGAL EFFORTS TO STOP BIDEN.
INSIDE OF TEXAS IT IS
FASCINATING.
THERE IS A DIVIDE BETWEEN THE
TEXAS STATE SENATE AND THE TEXAS
STATE HOUSE.
THE STATE HOUSE HAS GENERALLY
BEEN CONSIDERED MORE PRAGMATIC,
SOMEWHAT MORE CENTRIST ALTHOUGH
STILL UNDER REPUBLICAN
LEADERSHIP THAN THE TEXAS STATE
SENATE WHICH IS LED BY THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR DAN PATRICK
WHO WAS KIND OF TRUMP BEFORE
TRUMP.
AND SO THE INTRAMURAL STRUGGLE
IS REFLECTED IN THIS.
IF THE HOUSE IS PURSUING UNCLEAR
IF THE SENATE WILL FOLLOW UP.
IT IS REMARKABLE FOR THIS TO BE
COMING UP AT THE END OF A
SESSION WHICH HAS PROBABLY BEEN
THE MOST CONSERVATIVE IN TEXAS
HISTORY, WHICH IS SAYING
SOMETHING.
NOT ONLY A RAFT OF SOCIALLY
CONSERVATIVE LEGISLATION BUT
ALSO UNPRECEDENTED MEASURES
BEING PASSED IN BOTH CHAMBERS TO
STRIP AUTHORITY FROM THE
INCREASINGLY DEMOCRATIC LEANING
LARGE CITIES AND COUNTIES IN THE
STATE INCLUDING GIVING THE STATE
AUTHORITY TO OVERTURN ELECTIONS
JUST IN HARRIS COUNTY WHICH IS
HOUSTON.
SO FOR THIS TO COME, THIS KIND
OF INTRAMURAL FIGHTING IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AT THE END OF
THE SESSION THAT HAS BEEN SO
IDEOLOGICALLY AGGRESSIVE IS
STILL SOMEWHAT REMARKABLE.
>> IT ALSO HAS A REALITY TV
FLAVOR TO IT AND PAXTON USING
WHAT WE CALL THE TRUMP PLAYBOOK.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT IS FAIR OR
NOT IN THE CASE BUT THIS IS LED
BY REPUBLICANS SO HE CALLS THEM
ESSENTIALLY RINOs AND HAS GONE
BEYOND THAT.
HE IS NOT ONLY SAYING I DIDN'T
DO THESE THINGS BUT TRYING TO
ATTACK THE INVESTIGATORS IF YOU
WILL.
HE SENT A LETTER BASED ON A
REVIEW OF THE SPEAKER PRESIDING
OVER THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES IN AN OBVIOUSLY
INTOXICATED STATE, CALLING UPON
THE COMMITTEE TO OPEN AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THE SPEAKER
FOR VIOLATION OF HOUSE RULES,
STATE LAWS, CONDUCT UNBECOMING
HIS POSITION.
WE'VE SEEN THAT IN WASHINGTON.
ATTACK THE INVESTIGATORS.
DOES IT WORK IN TEXAS?
>> WELL, WE'LL SEE.
IT DOESN'T SEEM TO HAVE WORKED
IN THIS CASE BECAUSE THAT
STATEMENT WAS ISSUED RIGHT
BEFORE THEY ANNOUNCED ALL OF THE
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT.
SO, CLEARLY.
IT WAS SOME SORT OF ATTEMPT TO
HEAD THIS OFF AS YOU SAY TO
ATTACK THE ATTACKERS.
BUT LOOK.
THIS IS REPUBLICANS POLICING
THEIR OWN AND VERY HARD FOR HIM
TO ARGUE THIS IS SOMEHOW
PARTISAN.
THIS WHISTLE-BLOWER COMPLAINT
STARTED WITH LOYAL REPUBLICAN
STAFFERS IN HIS OWN OFFICE WHO
BECAME ALARMED ABOUT HIS
BEHAVIOR, THE WAY HE WAS USING
THE OFFICE ALLEGEDLY TO COVER UP
FOR HIS FRIENDS AND DO HIS
FRIENDS' BIDDING AND HELP THEM.
SO, YOU KNOW, THIS IS ALL
BETWEEN REPUBLICANS.
TO TALK ABOUT A LIBERAL FACTION
IN THE TEXAS STATE LEGISLATURE,
YOU KNOW, IT DOESN'T REALLY
EXIST.
SO HE'S CLEARLY TRYING
EVERYTHING HE CAN AND HE WILL
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE HIS
CASE IN THESE PROCEEDINGS BUT
THIS HAS BEEN COMING FOR A VERY
LONG TIME.
>> YES, IT HAS.
NOW THE MOMENT OF TRUTH IS HERE.
I JUST WANT TO PUT ON THE RECORD
THE REACTION FROM THE TEXAS
HOUSE SPEAKER TO THAT, HIS
COMMUNICATIONS DIREC